Miley Cyrus isn't wasting any time after
her split from Liam Hemsworth after
being spotted smooching canoodling and
soaking up the Sun with Caitlyn Carter
in Lake Como Italy on Friday the 26 year
old singer is taking to social media to
share her thoughts on change on Sunday
Miley posted these two photos of her
posing in a sports bra and athletic
pants with the caption don't fight
evolution because you will never win
she continued writing my dad always told
me nature never hurries but it's always
on time it fills my heart with peace and
hope knowing that is true I was taught
to respect the planet and its process
and I am committed to doing the same
with my own of course Miley's post comes
one day after her rep confirmed to et
that she and Liam have agreed to
separate at this time after 7 months of
marriage adding that as ever-evolving
individuals the two have quote decided
this is what's best while they both
focus on themselves and careers her rep
explained that despite lovingly taking
this time apart Miley and Liam remained
dedicated parents to all of their
animals on like the luckiest ever hours
before the news of their split broke on
Saturday fans noticed that Miley was
sands wedding ring in all of her
vacation pics and let's talk about those
pics and eye witness tells et that
Miley's poolside kisses with Brody
Jenner's ex went down at the ill Serrano
hotel where they were staying
last week adding that there were other
people sitting by the pool and the two
women weren't trying to hide it at all
according to the eyewitness Miley's
sister Brandi and her personal assistant
and manager were also part of the girls
trip but Miley and Caitlin opted to
spend some one-on-one time adding quote
they were fully on a date getting drinks
just the two of them they even got a
couple of massages at the hotel the
witness tells et that Miley and Caitlin
started to be more covert as time went
on and they were making plans to
celebrate Caitlyn's upcoming 31st
birthday on a boat over Labor Day
weekend as for how these two know each
other
a source tells ET that Carter who split
from Brody Jenner last week and Cyrus
were friends and have spent time
together in Malibu with the respective
exes adding quote Brody and Liam are
both into surfing and our friends and
according to Brody's recent Instagram
post we might be seeing more of them
soon on Sunday generous bonded to the
hills new beginnings co-star Brandon
Thomas Lee's comment about Miley and
Caitlyn writing watchout pics of Liam
and I holding hands on the beach coming
soon meanwhile Miley clapped back
commenting @brodyjenner go take a nap in
your truck and cool off hashtag hot girl
summer et has reached out to reps for
Liam and Caitlyn
[Music]